[Music]  so what what's happening over there what  are you going through uh so I had a  procedure done which is basically you  know then they tracked it some of my  bone marrow stem cells made it  concentrate out of that mixed it with my  plasma reach protein that eats anything  to anybody out there now both to  concentrate and they injected it back  into my cap so what happens is that when  you have three solitaires this kind of  liquid what it does is it fills in  literally cracks and anything that's  torn so it starts to regenerate tissue  or just you know central the sales  through these guys feeling the inside  and I still feel like you know we have a  chance and you deserve it and I want to  give you a hundred fifty percent effort  and you know be physically as you know  as active as I was at my best when  nothing hurt so I want to come back and  win  [Music]